when we were chatting a few months ago i
said that hard times were coming
and today's numbers show that hard times
are here
hundreds of thousands of people have
already lost their job
and many more will what i would say
though is
difficult decisions do lie ahead for all
of us
but i want to reassure people that we
will get through this and nobody
will be left without hope and
opportunity why do you think it is that
the uk has been so badly hit i mean
you know the deepest recession of pretty
much any g7 economy yeah i think that's
a it's a very fair question to ask and
as i look at it i think
the primary explanation is the
composition of our economy
social activities for example going out
for a meal going to the cinema shopping
those kinds of things comprise a much
larger share of our economy than they do
for most of our
european comparative countries so in a
situation where you've literally
shut down all those industries for
almost three months for a long period of
time
it is unfortunately going to have an
outsized impact on our economy
and it's it's it's had a big impact on
the economy and as you say will likely
have an impact in the coming months i
mean
what can we expect in terms of you know
the economy in terms of people's jobs
well the employment picture as i've said
is
difficult hundreds of thousands of
people have already lost their jobs
many more will uh that is incredibly sad
and why it's so important that we focus
on trying to
help those people which is why we
outlined our plan for jobs
in july to support protect and create
jobs across the united kingdom
and whether it's through the job
retention bonus whether it's through
initiatives like eat out to help
out or the kickstart scheme for young
people or new apprenticeship incentives
i want to provide people with new
opportunities
one of the things that i think is in
everyone's mind at the moment is the
possibility of there being a second
surgeon
in cases across the uk if that does
happen
are you prepared potentially to shut
down parts of the economy again whether
that's pubs or restaurants and
you know the bits that have just
reopened right now the prime minister
said that might have to happen if
schools are going to reopen
i think the prime minister's been very
clear i think we're dealing with an
unprecedented pandemic it would be wrong
for me or anyone to sit here and say we
have a perfect crystal ball on
on how the future is is going to be but
obviously we we've evolved to a new
strategy now
which you know shows enormous promise
which is the ability to target our
interventions
in a much more nuanced way and that's
the success of our track and trace
operation
the testing capacity and so now we can
intervene at a local level
at an earlier stage and be much more
targeted in our approach and
you know so far that that is working and
that's very much how we plan to deal
with this going forward but if that
doesn't work you know that is still
early days if that doesn't work you're
prepared are you to do
bigger lockdowns across larger parts of
the economy are you
i think i think we've shown you can see
from our actions whether it's on
things like travel or indeed intervening
in local areas
in varying degrees that we will take the
action that's required
to suppress the spread of the virus and
do that in a way
that you know allows as much of the
economy to function as possible
you know that remains our our guiding
principle but as i said
i can't pretend that i have a crystal
ball given we're dealing with an
unprecedented situation and
and one of the things that's been
reported recently is the possibility you
know you may consider
changing uh the scope of the spending
review potentially
the the date of the the budget if there
is a second surge i mean
are those things that are possible
we've said that we plan to have a fiscal
event in the autumn and we're very much
working towards
that goal indeed on the spending review
which sets
all the budgets for people's departments
uh for the next few years i launched
that process just a few weeks ago by
writing to departments so you know we're
on track
for that but but you know it could be a
one year it could be a three-year
thing you know there's quite different
scopes in terms of how ambitious you're
going to be
and how much of a vision you can have
for the uk economy in the next few
months
well i think we're leaving at a time of
unprecedented uncertainty economically
and grappling with something that we
haven't done before so again i think we
you know we should have some humility
about the situation we're in
but our plan very much as i said is to
have a fiscal event in the autumn and
that's what we're working towards
you've probably seen the pictures over
the course of the last few
weeks of um dinghies in the channel of
people
trying to get to this country um and
you'll know about the government's
reaction to that what's your impression
when you see those pictures
well i share with with most people an
enormous sense of anger and frustration
that this is still happening this is
something that people rightly believe
um should be stopping france is a safe
country people should not be traveling
from france to come to the uk
for asylum purposes the immigration
minister has has been in france engaging
uh with our allies over there obviously
this is something that we have to tackle
jointly and he's working very hard
to put in place whatever measures are
required to do exactly that
finally when you when you look at the
numbers that we've just seen you know 24
20.4 in terms of the fall in gdp
was that just a price worth paying for
keeping the disease under control i
think we we took the decisions that we
did at the time we did in order to
protect people's lives and suppress the
spread of the
virus and those were the right decisions
but it's also
now right given the progress we've made
to
have safely reopened our economy it's
not a sustainable situation
to have vast swathes of our economy
essentially shut down
and that's why we have been able to
successfully reopen bits and do it in a
safe way and as people
get back to going shopping or going out
for a meal or indeed getting back to
their office they will see that it's a
new normal it's a safe normal
we have made changes guidance is there
to ensure that safety
and crucially mean that we can get our
lives back to normal get the economy
going again but do so in a way that
maintains our suppression of the virus
and they shouldn't be too nervous about
the virus should they
no i think as people will see as they go
out whether it's to a shop whether it's
to a restaurant whether it indeed
is back to their office i think they
will see changes and those changes are
quite
tangible and people should take
confidence from those changes to know
that this is now a new safer environment
for me to go and do all those things and
that's good news i think we need to get
the economy going we talked about jobs
earlier in this interview
and we want to try and protect as many
jobs as possible that comes from
as much of our economy returning to
normal as possible and that's why we're
so focused on these things